Hemos realizado esta convocatoria
aquí frente a este mural
que se llama la luz de la esperanza,
que es 1 mural
del año 2 011 que refleja el compromiso
eh con la Paz y la solidaridad
que de alguna manera esta esta sociedad vasca
viene demostrando desde hace muchos años.
Sin IR más lejos,
el pasado Domingo en Donostia,
1 manifestación masiva
convocada por el Mundo de la cultura
mostraba ese compromiso de la sociedad vasca por la Paz
y en 1 momento en el que en Europa
la mayoría de los gobiernos aparecen,
parecen tener especial interés en alentar
1 ambiente de guerra y en
preparar 1 escalada armamentística.
Desde el carrequín podemos,
Alianza Verde hacemos 1 llamamiento 1 vez más a la Paz.
Somos el partido de no a la guerra
y lo decimos claramente
y lo decimos con valentía,
tanto en Ucrania, donde el conflicto se está largando
sin que se materialicen esfuerzos reales
por la Paz y la diplomacia,
como en Gaza, donde asistimos a 1 genocidio
en directo por parte de Israel.
Por eso desde el carrequín podemos
queremos hacer 1 llamamiento nuevamente,
la sociedad no quiere
prepararse para la guerra y pide urgentemente
1 alto al genocidio en Gaza,
por eso decimos en voz Alta y Clara,
no a la guerra